Fox News host Trump brown noser and vile
propagandist conspiracy theorist Maria
Bartiromo has Unleashed maybe the
wackiest balloon conspiracy theory I
heard in the last 24 hours
Maria's suggestion is she's just asking
questions remember
did the balloon
okay let me even back it up did China
send the balloon so that it would be
popped by Biden so that then it would
disperse surveillance products that are
solar powered to now allow unlimited
surveillance I read a science fiction
book with technology like this let's
listen to what Maria Bartiromo says Miss
China didn't drop and disperse
surveillance products powered by solar
energy to allow unlimited surveillance
and why did it take U.S officials so
long to shoot it down was it a test for
the CCP to see if it can send something
into America's airspace undetected right
and how much surveillance is communist
China performing on America right now
right so of course China is performing
surveillance on the U.S the U.S is
performing surveillance over China U.S
is performing surveillance over Russia
and Russia over the U.S this is sort of
the way things work but this is a wacky
wacky conspiracy theory and it's funny
on a couple levels first of all
these right Wingers are constantly
talking about how unreliable solar
energy is you know when it's cloudy it
doesn't work did you know them when
there's no sun when it's night time you
don't get any solar energy okay all of a
sudden the very technology they claim is
worthless and shouldn't really be a part
of American Energy Mix they are saying
it's being used in the most
sophisticated way we can imagine
which is that the balloon was filled
with solar-powered surveillance Elements
which have now been dispersed across the
United States because the balloon was
popped by stupid Joe Biden fine first it
was Biden won't pop the balloon now it's
Biden popped it but is that exactly what
China wanted Biden to do the other funny
thing about it is the military under
Biden's orders waited until the balloon
was over water to pop it so that it
wouldn't present a risk to people and so
whatever was just released I guess is
now doing surveillance on the bottom of
the ocean or whatever the case may be
um I actually wonder if the balloon is
what made that massive dump of ballots
on Election night we should really look
into that one other funny clip here
related to this a Republican senator
Marco Rubio
was interviewed by uh ABC's Jonathan
Carl and Rubio showed up and he says you
know what China the message China was
sending was you guys you the United
States under Biden you're not going to
do anything about this balloon and then
Jonathan Carl points out well it was
actually shot out of the sky and Rubio's
like yeah but and then he inserts a
wacky word salad get over the sky and
the message they were trying to send is
what they believe internally and that is
that the United States is a once great
superpower that's hollowed out that's in
Decline and the message they're trying
to send the world is look these guys
can't even do anything about a balloon
flying over U.S airspace how can you
possibly count on them if if something
were to happen in the indo-pacific
region you're going to count how can you
count on them if they're not going to do
anything about a balloon over U.S
airspace right except they did how are
they going to come to the aid of Taiwan
or stand with the Philippines or Japan
or India if when the Chinese move on
their territories so I think that that's
really the the key part here is they
they knew exactly what they were doing
and and there was a message behind it
but the balloon was shot out of the sky
what do you mean I mean the balloon was
taken down
yeah and I think they understood that
ultimately that would probably be what
would could happen and then they would
make this other statement about all the
US is overreacting it's just a weather
balloon look how silly they got that's
part of it as well but what they know
the world is going to see is you have a
balloon that entered through the Alaska
traversed everywhere from Idaho and
Montana across the Midwest over some of
the most sensitive I mean look at the
flight path that this thing took it's
not coincidental it went over right so
first the problem is listen they do this
and they know we're not going to do a
damn thing about it well but we did we
shot it out of the sky right but look at
the flight path that it took and anyway
they had a response cued up these people
will say anything they will be
confronted with the facts and then they
will just spit out another word salad
it's conspiracies and meaningless
rhetoric all the way down is there a
real story here about surveillance of
course there is of course there is is
the story being taken seriously by
people like Marco Rubio and Maria
Bartiromo you know the answer of course
the answer is no